[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
Severus Snape Harry Potter and the sword
of Godric Gryffindor the Sword of
Gryffindor was an ancient sword over a
thousand years old
it was goblin made and originally
belonged to Godric Gryffindor one of the
four founders of Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry coated in
basilisks venom the sword was the
perfect tool for the trio to go out and
destroy some Horcruxes but first harry
had to find it
harry was of course first presented with
the sword when he was fighting the
basilisk in the chamber of secrets the
sword materialized inside of the sorting
hat and appeared infront of Harry
allowing him to defeat the basilisk and
save Ginny the sword was originally in
Dumbledore's possession and before he
died he entrusted the sword to Harry in
his will
unfortunately however Rufus Scrimgeour
the current Minister for magic refused
to give it to Harry as he felt that it
was not Dumbledore's to give away Rufus
took the sword to the ministry for
examination but did eventually return it
to Dumbledore's office once it was
returned members of Dumbledore's Army
attempted to steal it but were caught at
this point in time Snape had passed on a
counterfeit version of the sword to
Bellatrix who stored it in her Gringotts
vault Snape kept the real sword in his
own possession in the Deathly Hallows
Harry and the trio are out hunting
Horcruxes and Harry knows that he needs
to find this sword when it's discovered
where Harry Ron and Hermione are camping
out Dumbledore instructs tape to give
Harry the real sword however he also
explains the Snape that Harry mustn't
know that it was him who presented him
with the sword this is because Voldemort
could potentially use legitimacy on
Harry and figure out Snape true
allegiance so instead of just giving
Harry the sword he puts it in a frozen
lake in the Forest of Dean he then uses
his corporeal return us to guide Harry
to the sword but why would Snape leave
the sword in a frozen lake isn't that
dangerous the water was cold enough that
Harry could have gotten hypothermia so
why the added risk why make it so hard
to retrieve we later find out that there
was a necessity for Harry to retrieve
the sword under dangerous circumstances
in an act of bravery in Snape's memory
at the end of the book
we see Dumbledore explain this to him
good very good
cried the portrait of Dumbledore behind
the Headmaster's chair now Severus
the sword do not forget that it must be
taken under conditions of need and valor
and he must not know that you give it if
Voldemort should read her his mind and
see you acting for him it's hard to say
what would happen if the sword was just
easily obtained as this is never clearly
explained but my theory is that it would
perhaps just return to the sorting hat
when Harry arrives at the lake the text
suggests that Harry is aware of the
bravery component when obtaining the
sword what was it Harry asked himself
walking again the Dumbledore had told
him the last time he had retrieved the
sword only a true Gryffindor could have
put that out of the hat and what were
the qualities that defined a Gryffindor
a small voice inside Harry's head
answered him their daring nerve and
chivalry said Gryffindor's apart harry
stopped walking and that's his long sigh
his smoky breath dispersing rapidly upon
the frozen air he knew what he had to do
if he was honest with himself he thought
it might come to this from the moment he
had spotted the sword through the ice
and that's pretty much why the sword was
hidden in icy lake sure Snape probably
could have been a little bit more
inventive but this was quick easy and he
would have been able to save Harry had
things gone awry and that's it for this
video I hope you enjoyed it as always
leave your video suggestions down below
until next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]